earlier this week Leonardo DiCaprio  played a hilarious prank on his good pal  Jonah Hill nearly startling him to death  by running up to him on a New York  Street corner pretending to be a crazed  fan and such an insane story he was with  the actor at the premiere of his film  war dogs on Wednesday in New York where  he told us the prank was all in good fun  it was just funny I was totally taken  off-guard I was Jonah is equally stoked  about his new crime war comedy film he  praised director Todd Phillips super  proud of them  you know you try your best but you know  Tom made a really really great movie and  it's exciting to show oh ok war dogs hit  theaters August 19